i know i'm a little late to the moon
night game but at the point i was like
yeah you go for watching moon night
episodes you know episode episode and
maybe do videos about it i was like i'll
just do a video about episodes one and
two and then go from there and as for
this video sponsor really fun one this
video is brought to you by display
display offers high quality prints on
metal with millions of options on their
website we're talking comics anime
movies video games that's right chrono
trigger and night trap i'm jeremy
welcome to my channel and displaying
them is really easy just wipe down the
wall stick the magnet and the print
hangs right there if you ever run into
that moment like wait a minute i didn't
hang night trap changing out your
display is as easy as sticking a magnet
to your fridge so click the link in the
description get yourself 26 off of one
or two prints or 36 off of three or more
prints that is a limited time offer so i
do encourage you to check it out quickly
and thank you once again to display for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
and now that character i got for free in
marvel heroes but never really played as
because i didn't know much about him
well now he has a new shot and i gotta
say in parts moon knight feels like it
could be something special on the other
hand when it becomes
subpar cgi in terms of the mcu will it
is that too but i'm actually glad i
watched the first two episodes of moon
knight back to back in the first episode
of moon night you have oscar isaac and
he plays uh stephen adding another
steven to the mcu roster
marvel loves through steves and stevens
steven's a charmingly befuddled fellow
who works in the gift shop of a museum
he really loves egyptian culture but
which ancient egyptian history it's one
of the things that's drawn me to this
show because i love it too i mean the
warhammer armies iraq have some
connective tissue with something that
reminds me of ancient egypt but he seems
like a nice guy but then he'll black out
and he'll lose time he'll either wake up
in his bed or he'll wake up and a bunch
of people around him are just
dead or unconscious like i'll do this
thing like
his
fists are all bloody people are just
laid out i mean granted there are people
are going to cause some problems so they
deserved it but i love that first
episode because he doesn't really become
moon knight that you see until the very
end of the episode the outfit is
actually really sweet looking but i love
the weird psychological almost horror
element they were playing up i mean it's
never as dark as it could be but i
really liked this new flavor they were
throwing into it because the entire
first episode was all why is he losing
time what's going on i felt lost in a
really good way ethan hawks like this
dude starting a cult which
i see he's copied my hair because like
all the elements were there for me to be
like this is this is gripping me and if
for nothing else i watched the first
episode of moon night last night because
i had to i was like all right i should
watch this before the second episode
comes out so i can do a video in the
first two episodes was now that i didn't
want to watch moon night i just didn't
want to watch anything at that time
because i was really tired but i was
like it needs to happen now so i played
it 15 minutes in i was hooked i didn't
want the episode to end and that there
is the mark of something that i think is
truly special and gripping and now enter
the second episode i think the second
episode answered too many questions too
quickly now that is bad i'm just i know
who ethan hawk is or at least who he was
it's like he was moon knight before
oscar isaac was moon knight he's kind of
like black adam and shazam he's the
black adam apparently steven who is
actually mark this
this voice inside oscar isaac's head who
is oscar isaac but it's like american
oscar isaac and steven's british oscar
isaac apparently mark has a wife out
there hasn't seen her for months but she
knows all about him being moon night and
so it's like this whole i run into the
chicken in the egg scenario where it's
like who was first is steven the actual
person and mark is this other
personality this other spirit this other
person who's inhabiting his body was
mark the original person who had the
oscar isaac body and stevens this
complete fabrication who thinks he's
been around for
what would it be 40 years i mean he has
memories of his mom he has memories of a
past there was a part of me that was
like how would stephen have
social security numbers because he
obviously has a job like how could he
get a job if he just appeared out of
nowhere but mark moon knight oscar isaac
being this super special ops guy with
fake passports i imagine he could get
that done paperwork wise so that's the
most intriguing part about this whole
thing and i actually could have gone for
another whole episode of steven trying
to figure it out and not really knowing
maybe he gets reminisce but like he and
mark actually have a conversation about
what's going on now i pulled the veil
back a bit more than i wanted but i'm
still interested and intrigued with the
premise there is an element of venom in
here though it's like when this egyptian
god monster's talking to him it's just
in his head and it usually says things
that venom would say like in the movie
venom you know it's just like punches
throat to each his face i don't think he
says he's his face but definitely punch
his throat or it was like crushes
trachea i wonder how the mcu reconciles
this though because eternals was a thing
where oh these gods are actually these
eternals these characters who
aren't gods they're kind of like gods
they're superheroes but they're really
old and so human beings on earth were
like oh obviously they're gods but
that's for certain mythologies i guess
in other mythologies like egyptian
mythology gods are real now is the time
for jim caviezel to come into the mcu
just plop down just bam has a spear
you know his loincloth his jesus abs
come on you want it i did like how they
had that moon knight suit that's
actually you know a suit
it's in this episode but they kind of
scoff at it when he's fighting you know
the invisible dog when he's fighting
vince clortho it's never as interesting
as the psychological thriller element of
oscar isaac trying to figure out why
he's blacking out why he's losing time
why people are dying around him i feel
like i might know too much and now that
this shift has happened where mark is
now in control it's we're just gonna see
moon knight play out possibly i hope it
doesn't lose that interesting and
intriguing steam that the first couple
episodes actually had for me but also
yeah like the jackal dog cgi is
it was funny because you look at wanda
vision and loki that was mcu cinema
quality cgi just in a show like they
were like no no we're not giving moon
knight that whole budget are you kidding
me we know how people like wanda and
love loki and this is
we have the data a lot of people had
moon knight marvel heroes didn't play as
him i blame myself i see elements of the
mcu elevating itself to something else
something more with moon knight in the
first episode especially the best
compliment i can give the show is i
actually regret not playing as moon
knight when i had moon knight for free
in marvel heroes now there's no marvel
heroes which is a crime against gaming
not as much as the gran turismo 7 micro
transactions but a crime nonetheless
where's the first two episodes of moon
night have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you